hello welcome back to big mood where the
moods are big and the dicks are
bigger yeah yeah the tits are bigger
well they're not they're not well these
two yeah
so we have a guest today this is jess
lazama
if you were unaware she's one of my
favorite people in the whole wide world
i'm so happy
she loves her
like almost 40 year old person i've ever
seen in my entire life
she's not ever she's not even close she
can't even be close she literally looks
younger than me she's not
25 forever asian don't raise him yeah
that's true you believe
she has a 23 year 22 year old
22 year old about to be 23 year old
daughter
yes when she looks she's 22 herself
i'm 23. yeah she has a 22 year old at 20
of jess with her daughter because they
literally look like sisters
i'll give you one yeah you're like who's
the mom
yeah try finding out yeah you have to
watch this episode if you're listening
because you just have to look at this
beautiful face
so gorgeous guys i love you you
literally make jlo look like trash
yeah jayla ain't [ __ ] can i can i come
back every day
yes you raise our hot factor
it's a challenge i challenge you to not
be attracted to this woman by the end of
this episode just try it
so true um so we were coming up with
like
you know a lot of things that we talk
about on the show is things that we talk
about in
our our chat are like um our group chat
on the
on the telephone
phone text messages cellular devices
and uh one of the topics that came up
are just like the different
masks that you we wear especially
everyone being in the public eye
um how there's like you know certain
things that you're scared to show
um and then you show them maybe a little
bit and then you're like oh no i put the
mask back on or whatever
and then like different roles that you
play throughout life and how interesting
that is
um i also think on a kind of tangent
related topic the different different
people that i'm around
bring a different yes part of my
personality yeah
but i while we were talking about that i
was like i thought of jess immediately
because we had just been talking about
this um a few months ago like
pre-covered
uh we were hanging out it was like
february-ish a lot of [ __ ] was going
down
yeah on her personal journey which maybe
we'll we'll get into
in a little bit but uh i do remember you
you're talking about it was kind of like
a breaking point in your life
where you're like i've always been this
person
and scared to show these other parts of
me because i don't want them to be
judged too harshly
and i was like no like that's all so
relatable
and i actually felt closer to you when
you share like little parts of that
um so just for context and i feel like
i'm talking
talking around yeah yeah um tell us a
little bit about like your
your journey yeah my journey wow it's a
long one um
39 and i've lived 15 lives yeah right
like
you really have since high school we've
lived so many lives um
for me vulnerability is so scary and
i think i was just telling nikki that i
think that uh for me
masks are moods and goddamn are we human
like
holy [ __ ] i also think that
forward-facing we put on the masks that
we think
people want to see right every day and
for the most part that means
happy bubbly positive and by default
that is my profession
i am a coach and so it is my job to hold
the space for people
you should see her abs and uh if you
think this is pretty
oh yeah check out that body yes and i
forget i have to hold the space for
myself
and that was a big point of contention
in my marriage and
a public figure and that's so weird to
say i'm a public figure
it is i'm just a professional oversharer
and so i shared my marriage and i share
my being a mom and wife life and mom
life with my audience
and a lot of times people think
i just have the sunshine shooting out of
my ass 24
7. and that's so unrealistic i'm human a
lot of days
it's so easy to draw the blinds
so do you feel like because you
think that people see you as that like
as this sunshine figure
that you have to uphold this standard
for sure constantly
totally i think people don't they see
one side of you and they just box you in
and that's what you are to them
and they don't realize that you're human
you have emotions um
i am a mom but i'm also just a girl
like yeah i'm just trying to figure my
[ __ ] out i'm a girlfriend i'm a daughter
i'm all of these things
and i've lived so much of my life on the
public eye that they've seen me
be married to a man they've seen me
divorce they've seen now i have a
hot ass girlfriend and um they don't
realize like
so many people's uh thoughts get pushed
on to you
and it's really hard not to like mask
your feelings
when you start to believe what people
say about you so you really have to like
stand strong and just really not give a
[ __ ]
but that's hard yeah i think a lot of
people don't realize that like
because you may follow each person for
different reasons like maybe
someone follows you because they're like
oh i relate to the mom side of you
um someone follows you because they want
to be in the fitness side of you and
you don't realize that like just because
you're following them for one thing
there are so many voices that that
person hears
that like tons of different opinions
everyone's got an opinion about you
everyone you're just soaking this in
constantly and it kind of like
um it kind of like changes
how you view yourself and you kind of
get more scared to share certain things
because you're like oh no that
that received a negative response over
here but then it received a positive
response over here and it's it's very
it's a mind [ __ ] it is and i feel like
that's why we have to be like so solid
in who we are but when you're young
you don't even know what that means yeah
like i'm 39 and i barely know what that
means to like stand
in my body and to know who i am and to
it doesn't matter what people say like
you are who you are and you just own it
and through authenticity i just feel
like you just
you can share your truth and people
relate to that so much more than they do
the mask of trying to pretend like
everything's okay yeah actually
i think mark manson we love him yeah i
think he posted something on instagram
today that said
people try to hide their pain but it's
actually one of the most relatable
things
yeah um is pain so like why are we all
trying to hide it so much so
i can tell you why because on the other
side once it is revealed people judge
you and criticize you for that pain that
you're going through because in the end
everyone's just quick to point fingers
as to who it is to blame what rather
than
getting people's experiences or like
hearing the pain and like
learning from her yeah because i
actually relate to you a lot but
the opposite in turn instead of me
coming out like a ray of sunshine i'm
actually
like the complete opposite um but but
then like i
and i ended up feeling a lot of a lot of
struggle with having to to deal with
that constant
criticism and also being so young
because i'm
30 i'm about to be 31 this year but
throughout this whole time that i have
been in the public space about seven
years-ish like i've been growing myself
trying to get to know myself and things
that i've said
five years ago still come back to haunt
me because it's like well you said this
like what do you mean like you don't
believe this anymore and it's like well
i grew like yeah like you're 25 years
old at that point
yeah exactly people love to call people
hypocrites as if
growth and change aren't something that
happens for everybody exactly
like i i feel like um i feel like that's
part of it though is that you feel this
need to put on this image this mask
because you're so scared of people
seeing the real you yeah stabbing at it
when really what they're doing is like
oh how dare you take off your mask i
would never take it exactly
that's exactly what's happening they're
going through the same [ __ ] like they're
making the same mistakes
these people are falling on their faces
all the time but they love to point at
you when you fall on your face so
and so it makes everybody you know get
all get all
caged in and like oh i gotta put on this
thing when uh when yeah you're right and
mark manson is right where pain is the
pain is the only constant
um in fact if you look at like any movie
like anything in entertainment it's all
written about pain
comedy is written about pain it's just
we laugh at it because the
character's pain is stupid but like
country songs they're not laughing at it
country songs uh dramas like everything
is written about pain because it's
it is like the most relatable thing so
it's so interesting how that's
stigmatized where like
we can't talk about it and then there's
people that are like well
there are worse pains in the world so
how dare you have this pain when this
and then pain becomes a competition yeah
instead of just like hey can't we all
just relate that we
that we all have it we have to honor our
happiness and we have to honor our pain
and i think especially in the fitness
industry pain is almost looked at
as weakness as humans we go you're in
pain you
mental health to me is so major like i
would like to lead in with
mental health than what it is to like
have a great body you know what i mean
mental health is so important and it's a
conversation people just don't have
and that's so interesting that that that
stigma exists in the
health and fitness industry because
that's literally how you grow bigger
muscles
is like you like break it down you break
down
muscles to build it up then they have to
heal yeah you have to give them
nourishment
and then they and a lot of bigger and
better yeah and a lot of rest
and a lot of self-care yeah there's a
lot of metaphors going on
we have to baby ourselves you know yeah
that's why babies cry because they're
just misunderstood no one understands
what they're saying
yeah i want you to understand me food
that's why i cry
they make you cry every day that's true
and if you cry i'll cry
yeah for you i don't have tear ducts i
don't cry
ever she never cries did you run out of
tears because i had a period of time
where i was like i think i just ran out
of tears like i don't know
oh wow that's really sad
that's better than mine i feel like i'm
a robot i saw you cry yesterday so i
know you're good now
you saw me got teared up my eyes got
watery
there's some water in there though
i cried now like i i regained the tears
somehow but there was a period of time
where i'm like
there's nothing left like i don't know
what else i can't give any more
yeah single mama stuff because i feel
like for me one of the masks is one of
the many hats that i wear is that i was
a single mom and i was a teen mom and
i never allowed myself the space to feel
my feelings because i had this little
human looking up to me for survival
and i couldn't lean on her to have like
a mental break or
feel sad or heartbroken or depressed i
had to like [ __ ] crush the day and
literally wake up and make my bed so i
didn't crawl back in it yeah
and um you had to be yeah the tough
strong
strong one and now i'm like please make
a tear so i just watch really sad disney
movies
to cry what's up bambi you're like i'm
not crying about me i'm crying about
bands
right for you but i could cry for i mean
one of you i just can't cry for myself
oh it's ultra sad i i i get that though
because of
like just your like how you were raised
and like being you were tough for your
siblings and then you were
then you had uh corrine your daughter um
who
you were a tough parent for and you
didn't have like
you were a single mother so you didn't
have like someone to balance it out with
like where you could go to a corner and
they watched you
watch your daughter to hide in the
closet and have a brownie or a twinkie
you know i needed a moment
yeah i didn't have a moment you don't
get a moment no i do now though i'm
living my best life here yeah you
are dude i think your story is so
inspiring i've said this so much too
because i just like i [ __ ]
love this woman like this is i just mean
she's my woman unicorn we're hyper brain
what excuse me what just happened you
finish each other that's so cute we just
start twitching over here
i love it people don't know what we're
talking about you guys kind of look like
twins too so yeah you do a little bit
i'm like both papa
how much coffee did i drink this morning
i'm like my eyes are starting to cross
yeah sometimes we're speaking a language
and people are like we don't know what
people don't know what we're saying and
we're like
oh we thought everyone knew what we were
saying the same type of papa
kind of yeah um she's guamanian what um
and then i'm half filipino and french
president
with some sort of white islander and
white yes
that's why you guys look similar and her
daughter
yeah we're triplets yeah we're related i
love that
you're talking about being a single mom
and all that and like it does give me
flashbacks because like
it feels like that was a whole another
life that i lived it's another life
because now you know i've been with
casey for eight years so it's been a
good chunk of isaac's life that i
have had someone to help and not
necessarily be
in the single mom mode but because even
in the previous relationships i felt
like i was a single mom because it
wasn't like
they were completely checked out of
being a parent um
but yeah like i remember so many times
of like feeling like oh my god i need a
break that's why for my birthday this
past birthday
i just i i had to have a vacation alone
i'm like
i need to get away it's like the only
time you've ever been alone ever in my
whole life
it's so crazy to me yeah i bet that felt
really good it was so
it was the perfect thing i needed and um
but yeah
i i do remember that too and i also
remember my mom because my mom was also
a teen mom she had me when she was 18
17.
and then so but the thing is with my mom
she did use me
as a crutch like she did lean heavily on
me to the point where i was like this is
traumatic like
i knew way too much about my mom and
like her her problems and like her
intimate relationships and like
things that i don't think any kid should
know and i learned
from my mom to not do that with my kid
but then sometimes i catch myself like
because i don't i also don't want to
keep him
in a bubble and not know anything and
not learn anything
and be coddled exactly so it's really
hard to find that balance of like okay i
need to
not cuddle him and keep him in a bubble
but i also don't want to lean so heavily
on him where
like now like he feels trauma from
learning about my stuff or whatever so
how did you handle that with corinne
like that's hard when you're saying that
i'm like i wanted to ask you if you ever
felt like the mom guilt is another mask
you know yeah because
we have to feel like everything's okay
we have to hold it together for the
family we're the president of everything
we're the president of the kids
president of the morning routine the
president of the food the grocery
shopping and the laundry and like
we also look at and we also feel good
and we just hold it together and like do
skincare makeup
we're the center of the [ __ ] universe
and the universe is
heavy so like i did you feel guilty
taking a vacation for yourself oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah
why casey had to convince me to book
those tickets because i was like no
like i can't like there's just no way
like we're about to get a house too
during that time i was like in bora bora
that's insane like maybe if i go to
hawaii or florida
like somewhere nearby like caribbean
like i'm cool with that too i just
wanted a beach
and that's it and casey was like no you
you should do this you have to do this
like board board's been your dream
destination like for years like you have
to make it out there so thanks to him i
did end up finally doing it but as i was
there though i felt the mom guilt too
like still like
i was i felt so guilty that like we
would facetime all the time too because
they were actually
it made things worse too because they
were camping and like freezing weather
and you're like tanning and bronzing
honestly i did have to like give myself
that space that you're talking about
have to exactly i had to give myself
that permission
to enjoy that vacation because there
were so many moments where i'm like oh
what are they doing like are they okay
like maybe if they had
whatever i'm thinking of like how to
help them and during this miserable
camping cold trip and i i just had to
tell my something no put the phone away
like just
[ __ ] your mom hat came back on it was
like do they have sandwiches do they
have all the
camping materials that they need there's
no toilet paper because we're uncovered
yeah that's true luckily you went
because imagine now you'd be like
kicking yourself
that's true yeah do you ever like when
karen was younger because
isaac's 12. i still feel that and she's
22. the mom guilt doesn't go away
checking in and if she's breathing still
doesn't [ __ ] go away
and i find myself like there's such a
fine line between being
her mom and being best friend you know
what i mean because we grew up together
i was 16. i was 15 when i was pregnant
with her i'm 16 when i had her
and so we grew up together it's like
being raised by your sister
who's also telling you that you have to
pay the rent and make your bed
you know what i mean and so for she and
i there's a lot of headbutting going
around and like there's so much
it there's a thin line i have to
sometimes like and it's hard because
also the people i've dated it's hard for
them to step into a role when you don't
know exactly what role they need to take
yeah so you just end up being mom and
dad
yeah and best friend and caretaker yeah
you guys are very simple great
yeah and then you don't give yourself
permission to take a break and we
negotiate
out of everything i negotiated like out
of taking time for myself even though
doing that would have made me a so much
more sane human
so we just cope and try to be as
balanced and like as
uh sane as we can but [ __ ] that's hard
that's so hard
i love tequila same but i don't even i
have dogs so
i have dog mom guilt now because i don't
have baby guilt that's where i
was mom i feel like the closest i can
relate to just being like if we're
out i'm like oh the cats need me but
that's like
joe and franklin oh they need me so
badly
i need to shape their future because
they're little babies
thinking about you dude i can't imagine
so many more questions i want to ask you
like so many things i want to like
do it i'm an open book ask away she's
here
sure like the audience is probably
thinking the same thing yeah well the
first thing that's on my mind though
is what deodorant do you use
i'm not even joking i have a custom
scent by native i created
a girl that's amazing yeah we didn't
know about this custom scent i fell in
love with them at uh they had me at
coconut vanilla
and i gave you coconut vanilla and um
and then i found out on my birthday they
give you a
coupon code and you can make your own
scent and so i like built this in
the scent that i loved and it's a little
flirty a little musky a little sexy and
it's me and then they put your name on
it so this is
my favorite actually the regular one the
sea salt and cedar it smells so good i
think this one's good for men
obviously lavender rose here um but did
you guys know that
aluminum forms a plug in your sweat
glass keep it from sweating every time
every time it's like the hard plug is so
disgusting to me
if thinking about aluminum plugging just
like a bunch of plugging inside of my
armpits just makes me a little cringe
um anyway that's why native never uses
ingredients like aluminum paraben
sulfates or talc
and they have over 10 cents including
rotating seasonal scents so there's
something
for everyone they're most popular and uh
are like the classic coconut vanilla
lavender and rose cucumber mint citrus
and herbal
and it's also risk free to try every
product comes with free shipping within
the us
and you get 30 day returns and exchanges
so do what i did and make the switch to
native today by going to
nativedeo.com big mood
or use promo code big mood at checkout
and get 20
off your first order that is native
deo.com
big mood or use promo code big mood at
checkout for 20
off your first order and after you put
that deodorant on you're probably going
to want to exercise or maybe work out or
like you know
goals exactly you can't just sit around
on your sofa all day
so uh noom is our second sponsor and um
i
personally love this app because it
doesn't just focus specifically on
weight loss you know a lot of fitness
apps they just like focus on weight loss
or muscle building or whatever this is
also
focuses on the psychological aspect of
like why you
form specific habits and how a lot of
those things that you're trying to do
like
lose weight or whatever and like you
need to understand the habits behind
yeah exactly what jess was meant to get
into mental toughness yeah you can't
just put a band-aid over it you have to
like actually go in and
seal the wound solder all that solder
that wound so
um i one thing that i did before that
before i did noom and i didn't realize i
was doing this was um
anxiety eating or stress eating i didn't
even realize i was
just reaching for snacks and like
stuffing my face every time i felt
like i was having a panic attack so
realizing that and like consciously
stopping that and
forming other habits in place of that so
instead of reaching for food i like
meditate now
uh is a lot of what noom is about and
like really distinguishing what the
what your specific psychological habits
are there's ease and convenience newm
works with your lifestyle how you eat um
you can eat what you want
in moderation because you just learn to
control those those habits
and um it takes you through uh
personalized courses so
your habits may be different than my
habits and it will find that for you and
help you
noom doesn't tell you what to do and
what not to do it teaches you how to
look inside your own mind and make
better decisions for yourself
and noom has one of the biggest and most
accurate food databases available and
lets you track meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance
you don't have to change it all in one
day small steps make big progress sign
up for your trial today at noomnoom.com
big mood what do you have to lose visit
noom.com
big mood to start your trial today
that's n
o o m dot com slash
big mood yeah yeah so what other
questions okay
i i want to know your insight your
experience your advice
um because you were in a relationship
you were married and this man was not
corrin's father
no and so you had to find a balance or
understand a role there with their
relationship right because i i seem to
struggle
a lot when it comes to casey
and then also for casey like [ __ ] man
being a step dad is like
the hardest role ever like holy [ __ ]
like
so for him he he sees isaac as his son
right but he doesn't get to have the
exact
same um what is it title
title or like like responsibilities or
or not responsibility
um execution of like how to parent
the same as if for his biological dad so
there are certain
there is like this unspoken red tape
around that role
and he struggles with that a lot and and
i think in our in our household it gets
kind of difficult when
for me in my role i see i see
my son right he's in this position
where he now he's getting parented by
casey casey's doing the best he can
but there's some moments where i feel
like casey and i's style
clashes parenting style or discipline
style clashes
and so then i feel like in that moment
i'm like [ __ ] what do i do do i be
a good wife and stand by casey or do do
i try to be a
good mom and like step in and like see
what i can do
for my son to help him feel like he's
supported
and all that stuff because i just
struggle with that role yeah i still
struggle with it because um
there's i didn't i never wanted like my
momming to be undermined you know what i
mean like don't undermine my authority
to teach corrine how to do things and
not to do things and
there's also a fine line with like me
parenting her and me coddling her
a difference between cuddling and
protecting so like protecting her from
the things that could harm her but
like not coddling her so that she can
make her own mistakes
and i found that i mean this is this
doesn't help your situation but
with joe who's my ex-husband he really
didn't step into that role until after
our divorce
he's a great father figure to her now
she actually just started calling him
dad instead of joe which she did
throughout our marriage
and like how old was she when you guys
got together she was 12.
okay yeah and i was with him for 10
years and um
they have a great relationship now we're
great friends he and i
and uh but it was always hard for him
because i wanted him to do this thing
where he would tell her
the things that he needed she actually
respected him i feel like a little bit
more than she respected what i would
tell her
but he just never knew what to say to
her without stepping on my toes
and not crossing a boundary with her
where one day i think the biggest thing
they don't want to hear their biggest
fear is to hear like you're not my real
dad
and that would crush me yeah and you
don't want that for him so it's like how
do you stand by him and be
a supportive wife and let him step into
his role naturally without
having isaac build up resentment exactly
towards you for
letting him struggle be mean to you i
mean be mean to him
and that was a struggle for me and i the
only thing i could say is that it's such
a huge conversation where you're like
if you see me parent if you see me um
telling him what he can or can't do if
there's something that you think
that's a conversation to have after
you've had that with him yeah because i
think what he and i would do is we would
have that conversation in front of her
and then she's just like [ __ ] it i don't
need to listen to either one of you
because you don't know what's going on
yeah um and we didn't parents usually
don't
we're figuring it out too figure it out
don't come with handbooks that's the
thing you don't realize until you're
older
we're like i'm at the age where i relate
more to parents than i do to kids like
because
when you're growing up you're like the
kids like parents are mean and they're
dumb and like
they just it should control you all the
time and then now
like being closer to that age and my
friends are all like parents i'm like
oh [ __ ] like it's really hard like
you're figuring it out like as you go
like there's no manual like
they just send you home with a baby with
a whole ass human yeah
they just make sure that they're
sleeping in charge of that life that's
it that's all they care about is the car
seat they're like is the car seat in
place because that's our only
responsibility once you leave this lot
it is on you to keep it alive
and you're just like pressure too
because like the kids you know that they
see you like a god like they stay like
you are everything to them
and you're supposed to have all the
answers and you're supposed to be
perfect and you know that
but then you're just like messing it all
up and you're like feeling guilty about
it but yeah especially being young too
because then you're growing and you're
trying to learn
[ __ ] for yourself yeah and then you have
to like guide another person too so i'm
like
expectations are so major because those
expectations are placed on us through
like my parents placed expectations on
me they kicked me out
but the society puts expectation
expectations on you i was the youngest
mom
always in all of her grades and so other
parents would look down oh yeah
because you know they'd be like this
young mom doesn't know what she's doing
and so i was always extra cautious to
have extra
everything's in line and she always had
her diaper bag and she was a good girl
and i would just have to look at her
she knew the look yeah same thing why
aren't you in a headlock right now
i don't even
two three i'm like don't let me get to
three because then we're going to go to
the bathroom
you don't want to go to the bathroom the
trunk comes out
my dad never even had to use he didn't
ever touch us
but he would take his belt out and like
he would
look like scary
type of sound just a sound immediately
that works i'm like cool
more than ever i never fell out of line
because of that it's just hearing them
say i'm not mad at you i'm disappointed
oh god i hate god i'm almost happier my
my dad was actually just mad he would
just yell because the disappointment
hurts so much more oh yeah damn
but yeah i don't know because like back
to the whole question i was giving
or asking you it's because um like i see
that right i see moments where i'm like
okay i need to step back let him figure
out his role
and and just let that pan out but then
there's like this like mama bear
that comes out in me or it's like i
gotta protect my cub yeah like why are
you yelling at her
you're going too far yeah you're making
your cry yeah
i know i hear you that's it's still hard
when steve tries to be like franklin
don't do that
i'm like hey i'm the mom hey don't yell
at him so i totally get it
dude it's just it's rough man that's why
i admire you so much i'm like that's
amazing
you know you've your whole story too and
then the fact that like i guess we can
move on
from that back at your experience i keep
holding it all close i'm not back at you
what i've
admired about both of you is from an
outsider's perspective i'm like
wow they like handle [ __ ] so well like
to me
you guys are doing it perfectly i'm like
i'm scared i won't be able to
to uphold that standard but i love the
balance like when you talk about the
balance between
being mom and best friend i feel like
watching you with isaac
um you are really good at being open and
having open conversations with him
um and letting him know like why you
feel certain ways about
about things rather than telling him
just don't do this thing
like being open and telling him why and
why you yeah i feel like that's really
healthy
and but then you also have boundaries
where you're not like going
too far into like your own personal life
and i think that's so great of you and i
also
just that going back to that public
thing like you guys are
going through all this and in the public
eye
and i oh geez
how um and especially with you recently
like you when you're talking about your
ex joe
i know joe i've known both of you for
that a long time i i knew you guys when
you got together
that's right and uh yeah so i've seen
your whole journey and it's been like
you guys were both trying
very hard in that and like you loved
each other i felt the love there you
know
and then but the public only sees like
the
the good moments right and and all and i
mean
most of the friends also see all the
good moments so i think
when you got divorced recently it was a
surprise to a lot of people
and that's so hard to have to like
feel like you're going through it but
also you need to explain yourself now or
like feel that you need to explain
yourself or
justify to all these people that didn't
get to see the behind the scenes
what was that like because i can't like
i can't imagine like
going through that and then having to
have that expectation on you i had to
really think about how i was gonna tell
our audience that we're not together
because a big part of our relationship
was so
forward-facing and but we only allow
people to see as much as we want them to
see
right and so social media isn't real and
it's the highlight reel of everyone's
life so of course it was the wedding it
was the honeymoon it was
all the good things we weren't pulling
out a camera and a phone every time we
[ __ ] yelled at each other and by the
way i'm a yeller and he's very calm
i would be the one my head's spinning
[ __ ] pissed boo soup is just spewing
out of my mouth and he's just like
yes and he's just like when is the storm
gonna pass and i'm like oh baby you've
married fire so i
feel like oh and by the way before
just for those of you out there who were
like that's fake then that you only show
the
the happy moments it's not fake how it's
not weird would it be
if she pulled out a camera during the
like yelling even though
it's socially acceptable to show the
negative parts it's only socially
acceptable to show the positive parts
but then now you're left with well this
is only half my story
now i gotta tell you all this other [ __ ]
though yeah why is that your business
why isn't it
it's there's there's so much that we
have on our plate to share and then
things we take off of it and
i do try to keep some things for myself
but it's really hard because i also
don't want to pretend
that i'm living a life that i'm not or
have it look like it's something that
it's not or it is something that it's
not and
um and then you know you know you've
been you've been my friend for 10 years
so
nikki knows all of my i've been in
loving relationships with men and in
loving
relationships with women and so when i
started dating lacey who was also coach
you weren't surprised by the way
everyone else was they were like
when did this happen and i'm like but
these are also
little details that you don't have to
share with the world
right that's just you're letting them in
again representation is everything to me
so i really wanted to represent what
it's like being
a true bisexual i've been married to men
and very in love with women and i'm in
love with a woman now
and they're just i felt like you were
dealing with two stigmas at once
like girl like so one was the divorce
like some people are very just
anti-divorce and like if you said
forever then you meant forever and now
you're
going back on your word so like a lot of
people that
are going through divorce they feel
alone like very very alone because
they feel like it's not okay to to share
so there's that huge stigma i feel like
familiar probably
right yeah all of those emotions and
then like them casting judgment on you
for
stuff that you're going through not your
not their business but then on the
like on top of that you um found love
with someone very special who happened
to be a woman
and it was the first time a lot of
people were hearing that you were
bisexual which is totally like your
choice whether to share or not
but you know i feel like it it's like
it should be celebrated it should be
like a really happy moment for you and
read
and instead it's like now it's got all
this like stigma you have to explain a
bunch of stuff
and i just felt like i'm so i was so
happy
when you made posts about it because you
didn't have to
but there's so many people out there who
can relate and who are struggling
and i think that bisexuality alone gets
such a
there's so many different notions like
people have so many different
judgments and stigmas that i feel like
are so unnecessary
um and you had to kind of like navigate
through that
can do you want to talk about a little
bit of sure what that was like
absolutely i think first to touch on
like
change like the the story line so
divorce doesn't have to be ugly and so
many people want
for divorces to be ugly because that's
what is in their mind
we ended very amicably we're we're great
friends he
actually moved back home and we sat down
and talked and he will forever be
i will always hold a tender spot in my
heart for joe
we just he's gonna make a great husband
to someone else
we just weren't the right fit and i
think there's so much integrity
in staying in something that's working
and there's a lot of integrity in saying
to the person that you love this isn't
working
yeah and i want you to be happy this
isn't making us happy
so before we hate each other and we
never speak again let's
break even now and there's also no
i love everybody was like oh but your
character and you have to have time like
there's no integrity
for me personally in lying to someone
for the k for the sake of keeping a
promise
i promised i would be married to you
forever but there's no integrity in me
hurting you
not wanting to be with you because we
drive each other crazy yeah
and by the way marriage doesn't fix
anything it just amplifies bigger
[ __ ] problems it really does
um and then when i started dating lacey
i was like i wanna it was pride month
and i really wanted to like represent
what it's like being a woman
in i can say middle age because i'm
almost 40 a year away from it oh my gosh
you you're making all the middle aged
women cry though because like you look
[ __ ] 25. live your truth baby i think
it keeps you young forever
can i steal whatever vampire blood
you've been drinking
um but i think that there was something
to be said about being a woman who's
been married who
is a mom who is dating a woman and who's
in love and just
knowing that you can find love and you
can live your truth and you don't got to
give a [ __ ] about what anybody thinks
because at the end of the day
they don't have to live your life and
they don't have to it's one foot in
front of the other every day for me and
i'm just trying to do that as
honestly and as authentically as i can
and if that offends someone
just don't listen there's nothing you
could do about it look away close your
eyes
what do you think like some of the
biggest misconceptions are about like
kind of everything you've gone through
or like what's the feedback that you're
getting that you kind of just wish you
could be like
no it's not this or that
specifically for marriage it was
everyone was like you should stay in the
marriage no matter what we really tried
we went to therapy we
gave it our all we were in it for 10
years i would
so much rather prefer we do it this way
than to stick it out another 10 and now
we're in our 50s
trying to start a whole new life again
and in terms of bisexuality i feel like
people always think well you have the
choice to go back and for me we just
talked about this it's not about going
back
to any particular gender it's moving
forward with the person that you
have like you just see that ability and
love people i just
love people you fall in love with the
person there's no like oh well i was
straight and now
i'm gay no i'm going to go
no matter what my personal sexuality is
is fluid and i fall in love with people
and they're you know sexy bits are just
a plus
and i think they're all beautiful um but
i love who i love and i just think that
if we can just accept each other for
just loving who we love then
a lot of people won't have to wear a
mask pretending that there's something
that they're not yes
you know i love that i just love who you
love love who you love love is love
love is love baby it really is how about
your your journey into
understanding that that's who you are
like how was that like discovery
i was 12 years old when i kissed my
first girl wow yeah so i've known for a
very long time and my parents know
you kissed a girl and you did like
but and that's that's another thing like
i feel like um when you say to someone
you're bisexual they think oh it's a
phase
you're just there you're touring you're
trying right like the college girl thing
too
like oh you're in your 20s you're just
trying to play around right
and like that that's what like gets
that's what gets us in trouble
my girlfriend has never been with a man
ever so she's considered and by the way
i never knew any of this was a thing but
she's a gold star lesbian and i'm like
what does that mean
am i a blue star am i a silver star am i
a titanium like what are the red stars
experimented with men so she's never
touched a dick
basically she's never been with a man
and meanwhile i've been married to two
of them yeah
and so i'm sure that was very scary for
her to get into because
we've had very open conversations about
what that looks like
like in terms of me being just like
we're not jealous people
i'm in aries so what does that luck with
that just meaning like we're flirtatious
but we're all so
territorial we have an astrology episode
coming later yeah
i'm going to learn later yes learn yes
she knows it's a fire sign she's fiery
fight and for her it was like
are you i have to be worried about men
coming at you and women coming at you
yeah i think that's the misconception
it's not that there's like
it's not like you're more likely to get
tempted because
you're attracted to both genders it's
like no you're like if you're in love
with the person you love with a person
it doesn't
it would be no different if you were
straight or or a gold star lesbian right
it's like you're with that person not
you're with that gender right now and
like oh well i miss
men now yeah no wait i have a question
yeah um so then when it comes to like
sex
sexual play not necessarily love anymore
like would it be for you personally is
it like a closed door like we're not
inviting anyone else into the bedroom
because it seems to be like a lot of
especially guys they think like oh she's
bi that means i get to bring a girl into
the bedroom like what's the case with
you yeah definitely not
um if she if joe or lacey ever asked me
to bring in another person i'd be like
i'm a one woman kind of show like and
also by the way when you're with me you
don't need any other person because
i they're there's just a lot of they're
so loud
and i'm very loyal but there's also a
lot to handle like
social media adds a whole another
element of trust as we all know you know
like
they're just conversations to have and i
think the biggest thing for us was we
were like if this is something that you
can't say
to this person on dm or text that you
couldn't say if i were sitting on your
lap
yeah probably not a good idea and you
probably should stay away from that you
know
so it's communication and trust and i
think i think that's like the
that is the cement of any relationship i
think bringing in
anybody whether that be a man or a woman
into your relationship is just
you should reevaluate your relationship
i mean some people that works
it's risky i think that's the that's
another one of those like misconceptions
like just because you're bi that you
just want to have threesomes all the
time
yeah no that sounds been there done that
and it gets messy
and also i think that a lot of times
people think
that when you say that you're bisexual
and if you say you're a lesbian
women automatically think you're
attracted to them but if you're straight
you're not attracted to every walking
dude out there exactly so
chances are you're not my type right you
don't have to be weird you guys get all
weird around gay guys
yeah you want to [ __ ] me right oh do you
want to touch my butt like no
you're not that attractive yeah i know i
get so frustrated for you
yeah yeah thank you and if you're
frustrated and you need someone to talk
to oh my gosh
beautiful segway i love it you're
struggling through any of these issues
you can talk to a therapist a licensed
therapist
online you don't have to go to an office
you can stay at home
you can go through the talk space mobile
therapy
app if anything helps reduce stress and
anxiety it's talking things out
talkspace has thousands of licensed
therapists trained in over 40
specialties so that you can find one
that deals with your specific issues
so anxiety depression relationship
issues and
more if you have something specific you
want to work on right now they'll find
someone right for you
so it's affordable talk space is a
fraction of the cost of in-person
therapy because you know those
appointments get they're pricing they'll
get hella expensive
but with hot space you can send
unlimited messages to your therapist and
they'll engage with you at least five
days a week so you could just
text them constantly you're just like
hey i need i need help right now is this
okay am i normal for crying
50 000 times a day and they they respond
to you that means you never have to wait
to share what's on your mind
it's also secure talk space is secure
and private it
uses the latest encryption technology to
store client information
and the bottom line is we all need
someone to talk to and talkspace wants
to give
the license support we deserve at a
price we can afford
as a listener of this podcast you can
get a hundred dollars off your first
month on talkspace
to match with your perfect therapist go
to talkspace.com
or download the app make sure to use the
code mood m-o-o-d
to get 100 off your first month
so many dollars or as gina would say
doll hairs
show your support for the show that's
mood because mood and it's at
talkspace.com
that's right feel your feelings and
sweat your sweat exactly
that's true tagline yeah yeah i love
that tagline
and if uh you know recently we have been
having a lot of free time
because you know we're in a pandemic and
i have been spending most of my free
time if it's not on one game it's on
best fiends because i am so obsessed
with this mobile puzzle game
and i really love it because they have
these like beautiful
graphics and they also have these really
cute characters and each character you
collect it has like a certain power
and that power like helps you beat each
level
because you're trying to trying to beat
the slugs by using your fiends
and it's super cute i really love it and
like i said it's a puzzle game so you
kind of have to figure out
how to beat it each level and they get
it gets really addicting like i've
literally been playing this game for
years and yeah so best fiends has
thousands of levels already with new
levels events and characters added every
single month
so like for valentine's day or whatever
they have like a valentine oh that's
cute
super cute so like they're constantly
updating the app which keeps me
personally
entertained and i never get bored of
this app so it's hours of fun right at
your fingertips and you can even play
offline
so back when we used to travel i used to
always pull out this
back of the day back in the day way back
in the day when you waste all your data
exactly yeah so i love the fact that you
can play offline
so with over 100 million downloads
and tons of five star reviews best
fiends is a must play download best
fiends
for free on the apple app store or
google play that's friends without the r
best fiends and think of me while you
play i do actually
every time i think of this app i think
of you yay by the way
i've been pointing my toes this whole
episode and i just realized that that is
kind of like a mask that
i'm wearing because i walked outside i
was painting my toenails because one i
didn't want you to see
that my pedicure has gotten so wonky
during this
stuff right now it's really my mine are
covered
they're polishing on my toes i have
nasty man feet right now this is a
literal mask
yeah so i was like i was painting my
toenails but then i had to go um get
jess outside
and so i just walked outside barefoot
and so the bottom of my feet are so good
just to point my toes this whole episode
that's exhausting
but i'm getting these shins working yeah
you're going to have half muscles
yolked shins in texas this is one in
texas we call that heb
feet shout out to texans that might be
listening heb is a grocery store and
some people like to go to the grocery
store or barefoot
so we call it heb feet in hawaii no one
ever wears shoes and i love it i feel at
peace there
but it's so gross when i watch people go
into the bathrooms oh yeah the
bathroom's the same
i did get hookworm from barefoot in
mexico
oh yeah but that was another bathroom it
wasn't it was just everywhere was you
were barefoot everywhere
yeah on the beach how did you were the
one that got it
no one else got it i don't know it's
just your luck
it really is it was and then yeah and
then we went to costa rica and steve got
a kidney stone and
just so those vacations were just cursed
a lot of bad luck anyway
um recovery back to us uh
and and just wearing masks and in
to the society what am i trying to say
society um i feel like
timelines especially for women timelines
are something that
almost every woman feels like they have
to uphold a certain
like there's this should happen by this
time and my eggs are dying and
biologically and i have to blah blah
blah
too many windows and stuff so how has
that played
a lot i mean your timeline you know you
had a kid a kid really young time
was all thrown off yeah i'm like
benjamin
buttoning at life right now okay so now
i'm living the life and i'm in my
teenage years
yeah that's awesome i actually did it
right so
right i'm kind of jealous like
low-grown-ass kids like i wish i had my
kid all grown up and like
relatable to me already and it is
awesome
i know i don't want a baby now i'm like
i'm too old i feel like can you
can you give me a 22 year old exactly
you know we want to have more kids and
i'm like yeah for you too
like you know now you're married um in a
new relationship well not new anymore
but like you know not to isaac's dad
is and when you were with joe it was
their pressure to be like well
now new marriage new babies yeah well i
definitely
feel that with with the one i'm in
currently for sure he did
pressure or just something you want
because you're it's both
yeah it is both like i really do i do
want more kids so that is
cemented there like i do want more kids
that's put that aside
yes there's pressure because he doesn't
have his biological
kid right he wants to know what that's
like and now you guys are in your 30s
and so it feels like there's this window
for me it's the window thing
because it's like yeah i'm married and
yeah steve and i both really want to
have kids
but if i had to choose what i have him
right now i don't know
like because i i kind of feel like the
pressure plays a huge role
in that well in a few years will i even
have the choice
you know like or will the eggs be like
peace out we're done
so we only have like three left so
figure it out
dude and then now like you know we've
been kind of trying and stuff and then i
end up feeling
bad i'm like am i broken how come we're
not pregnant yet true i mean also we
haven't been like fully like
super super trying like oh my god it's
the whole week that we're fertile let's
have sex every single day we're not
doing that either like crazy crazy we're
just being really relaxed with it we're
like oh we just so happen to have sex
and unfertile
whatever not that easy to get pregnant
like after you're like
i mean i feel like from like 16 to like
22 you're probably like
but then after that it like it takes
women a year or something so that's two
years that's the part that
like i i forget to be kind with myself
for that because i forget that and since
i forget that
i end up being really hard on myself
also it takes two tango maybe it's his
sperm being lazy you know you don't know
but we do take all the responses
swimmers just like chilling and you're
like dying before you get there yeah
that's true you know yeah but then like
yeah and then
thinking about starting over though like
just that thought alone
daunting it is daunting because i'm like
oh my god isaac's already 12 he's like
my little best friend he does everything
like he's just so independent like
it's [ __ ] easy right now like to be
the greatest screaming babies
also i don't know if this is the case
for you but i remember you talking about
with corinne like what if i don't have
another angel
child awesome kid i have the spawn of
the devil
and like i don't have the patience for
the spawn of the devil you know what i
mean like
i barely had the patience for that yeah
literally my biggest fear of like the
next kids if we ever
do get pregnant i'm so terrified of how
those kids are going to come out
because i'm like i love you i could have
just stopped where you were i know
there's a direct comparison
before it was like maybe all kids are
like this but now if
the kid is a little angel baby different
personality i know
there's a lot of pressure because
there's also i think infertility is an
another conversation a lot of people
don't have and i think the statistic is
correct me if i'm wrong but it's like
one in eight couples have like really
end up having to go through ivf
and um and take that route that's a lot
that's a lot
that's a lot like we forget and then you
know
what i'm reminded of that is like during
holidays like mother's day and father's
day that there's we have to honor like
all the people who
you know some people have angel babies
and some people have babies who are
they're carrying them and um this time
in covid
makes pregnancy so much more crazy
they're delivering alone yeah it's so
sad i well
i mean the good news though is that i do
have friends that they just recently
announced that they had gotten pregnant
they've been trying for i think over 10
years
and they've gone through so many
obstacles it's great i actually kind of
want to have her on
and we could talk to her about yeah
journey too but yeah i mean it's so
crazy especially right now during this
time
to like oh that's why the pressure sucks
and people shouldn't
necessarily go into a conversation with
your friends asking like so when are you
gonna have a baby because you don't even
know that maybe they've been trying
yeah and you're just that's the one
thing that people need to absolutely
stop doing
please where are you gonna have a baby
when you have a baby when you're gonna
get married
never [ __ ] say that anymore like
miraculously be like
boom then it would happen already you
carry the baby yeah
you know the baby so badly you carry the
baby dude though what are you having a
baby
no that was a mom yeah mom come on when
are you having a baby
did i get it though because i've been
that person for a long time like like
with barton geo i was like the one i
gave them their first baby present right
after their wedding and they didn't have
a kid
all about that yeah i was that person
for sure i was just like i'm so excited
i see you guys
and i just i would love to see like you
know you guys create a human because i
know that that's something that they
also wanted so
yeah i think there has to be like that
like read the room kind of vibe
like wait are they even have they
expressed the fact that they're even
trying or whatever
we naturally want there to be life
created out of love but a lot of times
some people don't want to ever
be parents that's me i think i this year
finally i was able to say
because i was pushing it i was pushing
my my relationship with my joe i know
it's weird because there's two judges
two justices and two jobs we were
pushing uh our relationship into
marriage and i was pushing i was like
i'm [ __ ] getting old you know like i
don't have much time yet and if we're
not gonna do it i need to hurry up so i
can find the next person so i can get
the baby from that man yeah
you know and then so finally we broke up
within almost a year has gone by and now
i'm like you know what
i actually don't want to have kids and
i've been following some other
influencers like
i think i forget her name lisa something
tom billy's wife he's
some other influencers or whatever but
she's doesn't have a child and she
doesn't want to have children and she's
so she's kind of a voice for other women
who don't want to have children as well
it's totally okay yeah it's like is
there is there something
wrong with that like what that means
jess what you're gonna be the first
pregnant no i'm not
i'm not so we're trying and i watch my
fertility cycle and i'm like no dicks go
inside
during this week this is my no dick week
yes
you just like intentionally don't shave
yeah just to prevent yourself
from those crazy it's only a week i know
the window is weak
well like the like the egg is only there
for 24 hours
like you don't even know we're born with
the eggs that we're going to have
forever
can reproduce sperm until they're 98 and
we're meanwhile we're like
was i born with five eggs or 50. yeah
who knows
yeah and then the other thing is uh i
feel like the reason there's all this
pressure like later like where we're in
our 30s and being like oh now
there's this window now is because there
was already that pressure of like
career and having to discover like who
are you as a person and the career
and women have like are they have to
have like a career too
you know especially in this day and age
where
it's hard to even afford to live without
having
both yeah the pressure on a man to be
able to provide for two people is
already
so great yeah and then now so it's like
we have to pick up the slack too but
then now we have to do that and be a mom
and do all this other
[ __ ] it's like wow and not be tired and
not be tired and look refreshed
and never lose your temper sexy you
can't lose your cool ever
yeah yeah oh man it's hot it's just walk
around losing our [ __ ]
all day long you know what i mean i'm
just popping off all day long
i talk about how i melt into the floor
all the time like i just cry until i
melt into a puddle on the floor and
it could be any floor really like
sometimes in the kitchen
yeah i'll be on the [ __ ] tile you
know
any floor i can melt into any floor
you're pretty good at that
i think that's why i say like in the
fitness industry when i say that
it's sadness is viewed as weakness it's
not because that's what it's like it's
because when you
hire someone to be your coach you expect
them to be strong
all the time right and that's such a
high expectation because they're just
humans
yeah just like moms we're expected to be
strong all the time and it's like
what if the weight of the world just
feels heavy and i just need to put my
arms down
can i just take a break can i just break
can i just sit in the bath
without fingers going underneath like
what are you doing what do you think i'm
doing in here
reality versus expectation expectations
trying and eating cookies in the tub
alone
baby like trying to [ __ ] get in
you're like i just need one more bite
yeah it's so true though because i just
remember being a kid
and my mom had to have all the answers
like constantly
and i was one of those kids that asked
all the questions they're like super
annoying
but like but then why well then why does
the tree grow like that
but then why and then they just say
because i said so
yeah and i'm like that's not science
that's why it's good you give isaac an
explanation
i try yeah it's hard they want to know
specifically well you know why
i think for me was because i didn't i
had the complete opposite growing up
like i
had a very absent mom and i was just
like well
that's what i know okay let's not repeat
that cycle yeah
fully because i actually do find myself
falling into my mom's habits sometimes
especially like you know during these
times i'm like
addicted to a video game and i'm just
like okay and i
sometimes i feel isaac he'll come
because he's bored with his video games
too or and he'll be like let's go ride a
bike and i'm like
i had to make that conscious effort to
be like yes put the [ __ ] away this is
not important
let me go spend time with my time it's
like oh because
oh my god it gets me so sad when i
realized like
you were four years old like yesterday
what the [ __ ] happened
where has the time gone and the next
next thing i know i realized
i'm really taking every moment for
granted
and then like not until i look back and
i see like his baby pic even from like a
year ago photos i'm like oh my god
you're never gonna be like this again oh
[ __ ] i gotta
appreciate you right now i gotta focus
i'm just gonna stare at you yeah yeah
dude i did when he was born for like the
first two weeks of his life
i i could not take my eyes off of him i
was just so obsessed we can just stare
at babies all day long
right like just them breathing and
cooing you're just like wow this is a
magical creature i built it
i stare at other people's babies because
i don't have my own so i just stare
and they stare back and they're like you
know you want one and i'm like i know
baby i'm gonna rub up on me with your
little baby energy
you need a baby foot oh baby feet baby
collagen
i definitely do get the baby craze crazy
thing
like especially cute aggression yeah
especially like when steve cleans the
house or like
he's like doing something really like
like oh you'd be like fatherly
yeah he's like our little nephew he like
plays with him and i'm like oh my god my
ovaries are bursting they're just like
needed green babies in there it's like
shotgunning eggs into your fallopian
tubes [ __ ] yeah
yeah i feel it i'm feeling it okay okay
i hear you
yeah yeah man like it's hard how do you
how you [ __ ] balance things ever like
how do you just be a person
sometimes i see people being a people
and i'm like how are you even how are
you
being a people how did you do that how
did you go through your day
i think i honestly think no one knows
what they're doing everyone's just
figuring it out and doing the best they
can
doing their best impression of people
it's all a mask yeah there's some
delusional people that really believe
they have it figured out
i know but i'm like okay that's why i
also don't get the people
that um like if if they disagree they
just they can't just be like
well maybe neither of us yeah like when
it comes to just things that aren't
proven yet or like beliefs or theories
on life and stuff
they can't just be like huh that's your
opinion this is my opinion
neither of us really know the hard truth
they have to be like
that's wrong i'm wrong you're right
their entire identity is attached to
that opinion
yeah so if you're saying that their
opinion is wrong it's like their whole
being is their identity
exactly that's a whole lifetime built on
this one idea yeah
exactly oh that's heavy i just find that
so fascinating i'm like wow what's it
like to just
know like you think like to just be so
hard
grained like i remember feeling like
that i literally remember having this
thought when i was
when i was 15 and i was parting a lot
and i was doing drugs and [ __ ] but i
remember having this thought of like
you know what i know everything like i
literally [ __ ] know everything like
i can't learn anything new because i
know everything like how's this
i feel like it's a face because i feel
like i was that too i think you were
high during it i think it was
i really think i was but yeah it's just
so silly to think like
really you don't know [ __ ] like no one
knows [ __ ] the old one is 90 years old
don't know [ __ ] the older you get i
think the more you realize you don't
know
but uh yeah uh wow this hour flew by
thank you for being here thank you for
having me is there any if there was one
piece of advice you could give
the people out there that might be
struggling like with their math their
masks that they're
having super glue on yeah what would
would you tell them
i would say that it doesn't get easier
until you actually live your truth and
once you can stop
thinking about what everybody else is
thinking about you it's just easier to
take it down you know take that mask off
and
to just if you're happy be happy and if
you're sad be sad but like
living your life and living your truth
is
more important to me than anything
because that's mental health and i think
i mean that's a whole nother
conversation
but yes that's your development living
your best life
it's much more relaxing to just let go
of what anybody else thinks or cares
about yeah
just do you i think the anticipation of
it is harder than that
but then they're gonna all the scary
part they're all gonna laugh at me
dude that's so true because even just
superficially like with makeup i
remember there was a time where i
i really could not step outside and be
like have any other human see me without
like concealer
under eyes like under eye concealer and
then as i'm putting the concealer on i
might as well put the mascara and the
next thing i know i hold the whole thing
i have a whole face of makeup
and then not until we all took a
vacation in hawaii like five years ago
and i just spent the whole day without
makeup and i'm like
this is liberating oh [ __ ] because then
i was putting on like concealer that's
so ridiculous too because other people
are like
i don't give a [ __ ] with them but you
think that they're gonna be
looking at you like ew everyone's more
concerned with
how people are viewing them everyone's
in their own head
so true we're all ridiculous yeah we're
like if we can
i was like one of the four agreements
right like if we can just not take
things personally we'll just not be hurt
ever
yeah yeah if you could just live in the
present uh
eckhart tolle you're still your feelings
is wet your sweat
that's her that's a good tagline um find
jess
please go follow her on instagram uh
follow her blog what's your blog
so they know because just um i don't
know my name justlazama.com and i
actually went
in detail about divorce and what that
means to move on so yeah you're
struggling
i hear you really really good read i
cried i see you
and i wasn't even going through that but
i was just like oh my god this is so
i get everything going on there and i
love it i was trying to avoid anything
like that for the longest time but then
i feel like now i'm ready to read
something deep like that
you should read it i'm gonna go i think
later on tonight i'm gonna progress jess
yeah
so happy
[Laughter]
well take your mask off have some fun
live your life
don't care about other people's opinions
and we'll see you on the next one
bye